the magnificence of the Amazon
rainforest is being burnt to the ground
every single day
this is one of the latest illegal
attacks on the forest it happened just a
few weeks ago
they're clearing the forest to make
grazing land for beef
this Devastation has exploded under the
presidency of Jay bolsonaro what's
concerning about this attack is that
it's in the heart of protected
indigenous land
the carapuna have been here for
Generations
once remote their Community has been
decimated by disease from Outsiders
their numbers have dwindled
now they're losing their hunting land at
an astonishing rate
their leader took me just three
kilometers from their Village to show me
how the loggers and ranchers are moving
in
their Road in and out of their Community
was closed for a year by gun toting
felling teams
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
like so many of the indigenous groups in
the Amazon they depend on the forest and
the Amazon River's many tributaries to
survive
the forest is disappearing and so too
are the animals and fish that the
indigenous live off
[Music]
bandolator tuna used to live on the
river until he was forced out of his
home by a Rancher with a gun
we stopped opposite his land he left
because he had no choice
this is the problem these communities
face they're being squeezed out their
land is being taken and their backs are
to the water
the indigenous people make the point
that no government in Brazil has ever
looked after the forest in the way that
they think it should be they also say
that this election is really crucial for
its future the bolsonaro wins they say
it could actually disappear if Lula wins
well at least it stands a chance
while the trees are being destroyed the
Amazon's rivers are being polluted by
thousands of dredgers looking for gold
you can see them moored up waiting to
work at night
after accusations of inaction the
federal police have now launched a short
operation targeting some of the dredgers
in a quite spectacular way
the hulks of the boats burning in the
river for miles
but there are still thousands left
dredging even now
the operation sparked process in the
city of Portobello
they blocked the main road to the port
throughout the night
[Applause]
these illegal dredgers are now out of
business on the direct orders of a
bolsonaro appointed minister
yet counter-intuitively they blame his
opponent Lula de Silva
is
supporters of both would be presidents
agree on one thing that this election
could decide the very future of the
Amazon
bolsonaro's believe in its exploitation
lulers in its conservation
another subject in this divisive
election where there is no common ground
Stuart Ramsey Sky News in the Amazon
rainforest